CBS News chief congressional
correspondent Nancy Cordes and CBS news
political correspondent Edie O'Keeffe
join us to discuss all this welcome to
both of you all right
Edie let's take a look at some of those
exit polls about why there was such
massive turnout we learned that
two-thirds of those who voted said they
were voting to send a message to Trump
1/4 of voters casted in support of the
president 4 in 10 cast votes to oppose
him 1/3 said it had nothing to do with
him but that signals that the president
much as he wanted it to be much as we
expected it would be it became about him
what about the number of moderate
Republicans who lost their seats in the
House a dying breed at this point we're
down to basically we'll heard of Texas I
know we'll be here later this morning
guys like Carlos corbello in the Miami
area lost mike coffman in the Denver
suburbs those have been longtime
Democratic targets and in a year like
this they lost and those are the
moderates who didn't decide to retire
because they took a look at the
environment and saw that it was
inhospitable to Republicans in swing
districts and Nancy you cover the Senate
of course Democrats lost a number of
seats Republicans enlarged and their
majority right and Democrats frankly
were stunned they thought perhaps they
might lose the Heidi Heitkamp race in
North Dakota or Claire McCaskill in
Missouri they were not expecting that
Joe Donnelly in Indiana would lose and
now Senator Bill Nelson of Florida also
on the cusp of losing I was talking to
Senator Chris Coons of Delaware who was
not up for re-election but is now going
to have to say goodbye to a number of
his colleagues he said he's heartbroken
and he's worried about what this means
for the party because you have so many
of the moderate deal makers in the
Senate Democratic caucus leaving meaning
the Democrats who were living in
Republican states correct and they have
to cut deals to survive right what does
this mean if anything for Chuck Schumer
the Democratic Party now you know they
lost some of their races was the
Democrats think well you know
structurally it was just a bad year for
us or are they going to look for new
leaders right they are going to want to
avoid drawing any lessons from this race
because they're gonna say well look it
was just the map we were up in all of
these red states you know what did you
think was going to happen but there are
going to be some Democrats making the
case first of all we got to figure out
what's going on in Florida this is
supposed to be a swing state and
yet even in a year where everything
should have been going the Democrats way
it didn't well just a follow on John
what about all of those Democrats who
lost in red states in the Senate all
voted against Kavanagh the exit polls
showed that was a factor now whether it
was the factor whether it was a
contributing factor I think we're gonna
be sorting that out for several weeks to
come
Republicans would like you to think this
morning that it had something to do with
it and certainly we know that it helped
drive Republican interest in energy and
turnout in the closing weeks to draw a
correlation right but you know again man
these were states that the president had
won by big numbers they were already
gonna be on you know they were gonna be
big targets anyway and look at Joe
Manchin who won right you know did fall
and he voted for him that's someone like
Phil Bredesen
in Tennessee who was a potential pickup
for for the Democratic Party very
popular in Tennessee even though he's a
Democrat he said that he would have
voted for Cavanaugh and he lost Isis or
so yeah give us your sense then what
would have happened in those cases in a
Democratic Institute to where women are
very important to turning out your vote
if those senators had said I'm gonna
vote for Cavanaugh I mean there would
have been a downside on the enero which
was the calculation for Joe Donnelly and
for Claire McCaskill especially because
they understood that they needed to
drive up support that they did have
their and hope that there were enough
independents elsewhere they didn't have
them by the way if you think this was
topsy-turvy remember that in 2020
Republicans will have the problem that
Democrats that this year were seats to
defend in blue states there was one
moment of unity last night 8 and 10
voters said they want more women in
power in Congress holding that political
seats and women made moderate gains last
night we're gonna end up at the end of
the day with most likely one women more
woman senator than we had before so
instead of 23 you'd have 24 we saw women
making good great at race as well they
did and and moderate gains in the house
as well they go up a little bit from
their record but still a long way to go
yeah at a Nancy we keep talking for
hours as we did last night but
unfortunately don't have that much time
this morning great if you need us
like cbsn always on